Brace herself.
You're about to feel the learn so hard.
Hello world.
It's a Raj and the question I get asked the most by far is how do I get started
with machine learning?
I've created a three month guide to help you go from absolute beginner to
proficient in the art of machine learning,
and I'll describe it in this video.
It's for those who can only dedicate part time to learning since you either pay
have a job or B have to go to school,
but you're,
if you're able to go full time,
you could complete this in half the time.
This is something that I create for myself if I were to start learning AI today,
but I'm open sourcing it for you to help you out.
Let's start by looking at the hiring page for deep mind,
arguably the world's leading institution when it comes to publishing state of
the art Ai Algorithms.
If we look under the research engineer position,
we'll see a description for what it takes to be a part of the team responsible
for Alphago,
the deep Q network and wave net,
each of which revolutionized the field of AI.
The minimum qualifications or having a bachelor's in computer science or a
related field,
strong knowledge of python,
machine learning and algorithmic design.
No need to have a phd or have published a ton of papers.
Even under the preferred qualifications.
If we were to create a pie chart to try and understand the necessary topics for
machine learning,
it would look something like this.
35% of it would consist of linear Algebra.
25% would include probability,
theory and statistics.
15% would be calculus,
another 15% would be algorithms and complexity,
and the last 10% would be dedicated to data preprocessing knowledge.
We can build our own curriculum around this chart,
but wait where to begin?
I've divided this curriculum up into three months.
The first month consists of math and algorithmic complexity.
The second month consists of machine learning and the third month consists of
the most popular subset of machine learning,
deep learning.
But before we begin,
I want to first say that one of your daily tasks should be to keep up with the
field.
So here are the best resources to do that.
First is my youtube channel.
I'm going to be pushing AI content here nonstop every single week,
so hit the subscribe button to get notified of new content if you haven't yet.
Next is the machine learning subreddits.
It's a place where people are working both in academia and in business on ml
share their findings.
Twitter is also a really underutilized resource.
Twitter acts like a real learning feed if you use it the right way.
Follow really smart people and scrolling down your feed.
Unlike most social platforms won't drain you.
In fact,
it will enrich you with knowledge.
Ml researchers love to use Twitter.
There are some really good academic debates that happened there as well.
Some examples of researchers I follow are Elliot Sutzkever,
Trent mcconaughey,
Andre Carpathy,
Andrew Trask,
Pieter Abbeel,
Chris Olah and Nando defrayed us.
There are many more.
I'll link to them into description.
Hacker news is another must have.
The audience is well versed in the technical details of the topics mentioned so
you know that the only the best arguments rise to the top.
All of the resources I suggest are going to be video based.
I just learned so much better using videos and short form written content on the
web and by using a plain textbook that just lists equation after equation after
equation with no real life application.
Now on to the first month learning the math,
we'll start with the portion that makes up the most of machine learning linear
Algebra,
one of the most popular courses on Mit's open course ware website is the linear
Algebra course taught by Gilbert strong.
He's got a kind of infectious enthusiasm for this stuff and there are 35 video
lectures available on Youtube as a playlist.
Watch each one at two x speed if possible,
three x if you can handle it.
Take the time to hand write your notes as you watch,
not necessarily for your record,
but just to engrain what you're learning into your head that much more
efficiently.
Studies show that taking notes by hand really does enhance your brain's ability
to retain the concepts you're learning.
Then you can move on to calculus three blue one brown has an incredible playlist
called the essence of Calculus grants.
A friend of mine and I can vouch for his work.
He'll teach you calculus in a way that makes you feel like you could have
invented it yourself and when it comes to probability and statistics at x has a
really good course called the science of uncertainty taught by Mit.
You'll also find an awesome course on algorithmic design and analysis on ex
taught by UPN.
Dedicate a week to each one of these courses even though they say they take
longer.
We're practicing what's called accelerated learning two to three hours every
single day of undistracted absorption.
You are going to be like a sponge.
Watch a lecture at a faster speed,
take notes as you go and complete one project at the end of every week,
preferably one of the harder ones at the end of the course to complete yourself.
Each of these subjects has a one page cheat sheet you can find on the web
anyway,
don't feel bad if you complete a course faster than what the authors suggest.
Learning is just about downloading data into your brain.
You can use tools to accelerate that process.
Now we're ready for it.
Month to machine learning.
I've got three playlists for you to watch an order,
learn python for data science,
the math of intelligence and intro to tensorflow.
Then checkout you.
Udacity is free intro to machine learning course.
It's pretty well made for the next two weeks.
You're going to pick some cool machine learning projects to complete and code
them yourself using python.
I've got a great compilation of ideas in the form of a good hub link to help
you.
This is going to help you develop a sense of when to use a specific machine
learning model and how it would work for an application specific use case.
I also recommend participating in a Kaggle competition.
It's a great way to learn and earn money.
At the same time,
it's this ability to categorize certain types of problems,
certain types of machine learning models that well-paid machine learning
consultants provide for companies.
If you can build this intuition yourself,
you'll be much better off.
I'd suggest picking and choosing two projects a week and building each from
scratch.
This will give you hands on experience with the pillars of machine learning
including optimization,
data,
preprocessing types of learning,
data set,
splitting and model evaluation.
This is all about turning sponge mode into code and a lot of the art of data
science lies in the dozens of micro decisions you'll make to solve a specific
problem.
This is the perfect time to practice.
Making those micro decisions and evaluating the consequences of each side can't
learn is a really easy framework to quickly implement some machine learning
models.
You'll find that over time to complete a problem,
you'll be asking yourself the same questions,
how to best split the data,
what are the best parameters,
et cetera.
At the end of this month,
you should give yourself a final project and that would be to code up the simple
gradient descent algorithm from scratch.
It's the most used optimization strategy in machine learning.
If you can code this from scratch,
literally everything else becomes easier.
All right,
onto the third month deep learning,
the specific algorithm called a neural network when given vast quantities of
data and vast amounts of computing power outperforms almost everything else.
Almost every time and that's why it's so popular.
Check out my intro to deep learning course on youtube.
Then checkout fast.ai deep learning course,
36 hours of high quality lessons for free for the last two weeks.
Just implement deep learning app after deep learning APP.
Over this time period you should have at least five to 10 projects related to
machine learning and deep learning on your get hub.
You'll be surprised how fast you can go from learning about simple perceptrons,
two state of the art models.
The difference being usually just a few minor tweaks in the architecture of the
deep learning space as of now is rich with technical literature and some of the
best stuff is free.
At the end of these three months,
you should feel confident enough to take your knowledge and either a work in the
field as a machine learning engineer,
be start a consulting firm or see start your own product based AI company just
to figure things out as you go.
Stop telling yourself that you can't learn it or you're not smart enough to
remember.
Learning is a life long process.
No matter how old you are or where you're from,
you can get to the point where you can make an impact in this field.
Thanks to the Internet and look,
if you don't like my learning plan,
make your own.
Do what suits you best and better yet,
get a friend to commit to the same learning path as you.
That way you can keep each other in check and not drop out as long as you're
giving yourself positive feedback along the way.
You won't give up.
Ai is going to eat every single industry and change what it means to be human.
It's all happening very,
very fast.
Either you understand it or you don't.
Which side do you want to be on?
Same.
So get started on your learning journey.
I'm rooting for you.
Was there.
Please subscribe for more AI and blockchain videos.
And for now I've got a course to lunch,
so thanks for watching.